la nouvelle est tombée comme un couperet
les professionnels de la nuit ont appris
pendant le discours du premier ministre
hier la fermeture des discothèques pour
au moins un mois aujourd'hui
l'incompréhension domine et l'on se
demande de quoi seront faites les
prochaines semaines la première fois on
nous a dit ce terme et ce trio au mois
de mars nous a dit on ferme sur deux
semaines je n'allais des semaines on
dirait bas presque un an donc là
aujourd'hui le 9 juillet on a réussi à
ré ouvrir et là c'est reparti quoi pour
combien de temps quand on sait bord je
ne sais pas ce qu'on va faire on va on
peut qu'attendre voilà c'est pas on veut
on veut pas des aides non nous on aime
la fête on aime s'amuser on aime on aime
tous a cessé nous c nous enlever une par
une par une par une part de nous-mêmes
c'est pas juste pas travailler avoir des
aides à voir on veut pas de ça nous
pourtant depuis cinq mois beaucoup de
choses ont été mises en place pour
assurer la sécurité des fêtards face au
co vide masque dans la file d'attenté
dans l'établissement vérification des
passes sanitaire des pièces d'identité
ici l'on estime que la fermeture risque
de déplacer le problème ici c'était
vraiment structuré c'était contrôlés ont
sélectionné les clients malheureusement
je pense que ça va juste promouvoir des
soirées clandestines entre nîmes et qui
est seront mal organisés et qu'ils
seront pas surtout sécurisé pour le
jeune public simplement pour les
discothèques le mois de décembre est
l'un des plus lucratifs de l'année
'l'annonce d'hyères inquiète donc de
nombreux professionnels encore abasourdi
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'économie
avait salué la résilience notre
résilience mais l'on peut plus ne peut
plus avoir de résidence un moment ou un
autre ce top on est inquiet parce que
derrière on a des familles à férvier on
a des employés j'ai une deux j'en ai les
larmes aux yeux j'ai eu une de mes
petites étudiante qui est en larmes hier
parce que la gamine a vient de prendre
un appartement
elle se dit mais je vais faire comment
dico pour continuer de payer
l'appartement je veux pas demandé l'aide
à mes parents c'est une annie sié ça me
fait mal au coeur
rendez vous au début du mois de janvier
pour une éventuelle réouverture des
boîtes de nuit